[Music]  question party is very simple  a bunch of viewers tweeted questions at  me and tarik and  we're going to answer some of them right  now are you ready tarek  i'm ready yeah here we go  our hitching  [Applause]  [Music]  they asked who has the better impression  of the other you were tarak  oh great question okay i'm gonna give it  a shot i'm gonna say you  but give it a shot um  the thing about star trek is you can  watch  any version of it and it'll be  just as entertaining as the one you love  all right let's find out what happened  the amber often story amber often will  be played by  terry davis you've been cast buddy  this was great let's do it again soon i  love you so much cheers  [Music]  you